We have our second postulate that the speed of light and empty space
is always c regardless of the frame of reference.
Now, this seems like a pretty incredible postulate.
We still don't see any good justification for why this must be the case.
For example with the train situation, why wouldn't the speed of the light increase
if it's coming from a moving train?
Well, there are a few answers for why we believe this.
One reason is that well it's a mathematical reason--Maxwell's equations
which are the equations that describe light.
These actually seem to predict a constant speed of light, though we won't go into exactly why,
but the reasons for believing this weren't just mathematical.
Einstein also had empirical evidence.
One important piece of empirical evidence came from an
ingenious experiment done by Michelson and Morley.
I'm not going to go into that right now but feel free to check out the link
below this video if you're interested in reading more.
The events I want to talk about came from Willem De Sitter.